Да ми гото готові
Дякую Шановні колеги Давайте я
прокоментую деякі речі щодо нового
проекту програми зі світової літератури
можливо цей коментар зніметь вже
половину ваших запитань і так в
зверненнях преси по-перше звучить фраза
що програма чинна на сьогодні 2005 року
є новою є сучасною і так далі Я вам
просто покажу як вона виглядає і можливо
деякі запитання у вас вже знімуться самі
собою це програма з пятого по 12-й клас
і в такому форматі її вже просто не
існує Вона працює на Сьогодні лише в
форматі 5тий тире детий клас але далі
відбувається ще інші метаморфози далі
з'явилася отака книжечка програма 10
тире1й і ми з вами всі добре знаємо що
12-го класу на сьогодні вже не існує і
повернення до 11-тирічної школи
спричинила необхідність об'єднати
програму 11го-12-го класів і відповідно
з'являється нова книжка 10 тире11й тепер
уявіть собі наскільки складно працювати
вчителям наскільки складно
зорієнтуватися науковцям коли для того
щоб просто викладати літературу в школі
з ятого по 11-й клас треба
зорієнтуватися в різних програмах більш
того я додам що Оця програма 10-11-й
клас працює в форматі трьох рівнів
стандарт академічний профільний тобто
вчителю необхідно спочатку розібратися з
цим валом методичної літератури і просто
книжок за якими він має викладати
літературу і перехід от з цієї програми
на 10й-11-й клас нових книжечок які ви
зараз бачили Він не є на жаль логічним
це визнають і автори програми 2005 року
і з самого початку коли старша профільна
школа розроблялася на кілька рівні
стандарт академічний профільний автори
програми були попереджені про те що буде
необхідність узгодити перехід між
дев'ятим і 10-м наступним класом
Оскільки у нас випало дуже багато творів
але справа не в художній вартості твор
На жаль Справа в тому що втрачена
хронологія історичних літературних епох
оцю хронологію А ми це домовлялися
одразу з авторами програми для старшої
школи і для п'ятих-9в'ятих класів що ми
будемо це узгоджувати Що відбувається на
сьогодні на сьогодні
2311.2011 року прийнята постанова
Кабінету міністрів України номер цієї
постанови
1392 цією постановою затверджений
державний стандарт базової і повної
загальної середньої освіти цей державний
стандарт розроблений відповідно до
закону України Про загальну середню
освіту який вимагає раз на 10 років
переглядати державні стандарти якщо
змінений державний стандарт відповідно
виникає необхідність обов'язкового
уніфікування навчальних програм і це
стосується не лише світової літератури
нам дуже приємно така увага
громадськості до предмета світова
література оскільки він дійсно є
художньонасиченим естетично наснаженим
він дійсно формує емоційний моральний
бік учнів але з іншого боку незрозуміло
бо є інші предмети із усіх абсолютно
навчальних предметів зараз відбувається
логічний процес уніфікації навчальних
програм презентації будинку вчителя з 3
по 5 квітня відбувалися абсолютно з усіх
програм єдиний виняток - це програма з
математики і інформатики вони будуть
розглянуті на з'їздах Всеукраїнських
2324 квітня тобто буквально от понеділок
і вівторок і що цікаво Як тільки ми
починали роботу над програмою світової
літератури а це відбулося 26 січня 2012
року на всеукраїнській нараді методистів
обласних інститутів післядипломної
освіти це ті методисти ті люди які
представляють в кожній області всіх
вчителів всю Україну методисти були
ознайомлені з проектом програми першим
орієнтовним ми його назвали тоді матриця
буквально тезово твір письменник клас
який пропонується і всім методистам всіх
абсолютно без винятку регіонів України
було запропоновано в місячний термін
подати пропозиції щодо нового проекту
програми Повірте що такого ніколи ще не
було щоб вся Україна на всеукраїнській
нараді в стінах Міністерства тут в
актовій залі на третьому поверсі була
причетна до створення нової навчальної
програми і за місяць на адресу
електронну членів робочої групи А ми ц
адреси оприлюднили на сайті Міністерства
26 січня на адресу всіх членів робочої
групи надійшло 3 000 пропозицій здається
2987 ну практично 3 000 з усієї України
ці всі пропозиції були опрацьовані
членами робочої групи Повірте це
абсолютно 100% завіряю бо я так само
отримувала всі ці пропозиції на свою
електронку мені дублювали члени робочої
групи ми це все опрацювали і проект який
був винесений 5 квітня на громадське
обговорення будинку вчителя це був лише
перший проект представлений широкому
загалу дійсно на публічний захист для
того щоб всі бажаючі могли долучитися до
обговорення автори цього проекту
програми навмисно його подавали в
форматі трохи збільшеному щоб можна було
щось скорочувати бо додавати ви всі це
знаєте складніше ніж віднімати тому ми
все ж таки враховували що ми будемо
скорочувати цей проект якісь моменти
переставляти з класу в клас якісь речі
урізати Тобто ми розраховували що ми
будемо працювати з тими Хто захоче
долучитися до громадського обговорення
Але перед тим як почала працювати робоча
група заступник міністра освіти і науки
молоді і спорту України Борис Михайлович
жебровський зустрівся з усіма робочими
групами і знов таки повторюся не лише з
світової літератури з усіх абсолютно
навчальних предметів і для всіх
укладачів програм з літератури це
українська література і світова
література було чітко визначено задачу
по-перше розвантажити програму оскільки
на сьогодні в програмі 2005 року ми
порахували дитина має з п'ятого по
девятий клас прочитати
20 сторінок
20 сторінок за програмою 2005 року читає
дитина з 5того по 9й клас по-перше
розвантажити програму і по-друге її
осучаснити оскільки в програмі 2005 року
єдиний твір який умовно можна назвати
сучасним це твір Рея Бредбері Усмішка
але при всій повазі до американського
відомого письменника який ще живий Слава
Богу Він народився в 1920 році твір
Усмішка - це єдиний твір який був
презентований як сучасний перше завдання
які ставилися перед укладачами програм
з'ясувати якими є сучасні учні бо на
жаль жоден соціологічний інститут який
проводить соціологічні дослідження не
зміг надати нам чітку інформацію що
читають сучасні діти е якими вони є що
Їх цікавить а ми всі з вами знаємо що
сучасні діти живуть в світі
інформаційних технологій вони зовсім
інші і не такі як діти які були і
вчилися в школі 10 років тому тому
з'ясувавши попит дітей і в сільських
бібліотеках і в Києва міста Києва і
інших областей регіонів України Ми
зрозуміли що сучасні діти читають не те
що пропонується більшою мірою за
програмою і пішли на певний компроміс
чого і вимагало від нас керівництво
Міністерства програма мала стати
сучасною тому в кожному класі з п'ятого
по дев'ятий з'явився розділ сучасна
дитяча література або в старших класах
це буде сучасна література для дітей та
юнацтва оцей попит був з'ясований з дуже
багатьох джерел і Повірте що в першу
чергу враховувалася думка дітей бо ми
всі прекрасно знаємо вони розподіляють
твори які вони читають за програмою і є
певна логіка укладачі намагалися це
відслідкувати логіка хронологічного
процесу історичного літературного логіка
художньої вартості твору І так далі
критеріїв відбору твору для програми але
є і думка дітей батьків і вчителів яка
так само була врахована укладачами
програми найважливішим є те що сьогодні
є звернення вчителів міста Києва від до
Міністерства щодо їх незгоди з проектом
програми але знов таки вчора відбулася
зустріч заступника міністра Бориса
михаловича жебровського з вчителями
міста Києва які підписали цей відкритий
лист і На жаль ми з'ясували що вони
навіть не бачили деякі з них тексту цієї
програми деякі навіть не були присутні
на цій зустрічі ми показали їм новий
доопрацьований проект програми вони з
подивом для себе з'ясували що авторський
колектив щодня вносив зміни А на
сьогодні після 5 квітня у нас до 700
пропозицій листів від різних вчителів
методистів науковців і колективні від
кафедр До речі від кафедр наукових
університетів на сьогодні близько 40
звернень колективних щодо згоди з
проектом представленої програми але знов
таки цей проект міняється кожного дня на
сьогодні в нас ще є кілька тижнів
серйозної роботи і часу для авторів
робочої групи які можуть внести всі
пропозиції всіх бажаючих і дуже прикро
що ее деякі дійсно дописувачі показали
себе ну в такому форматі
неконструктивної дискусії наврядчи
дискусії вони просто говорили що вони не
згодні з цим проектом не розуміючи що це
не остаточний варіант А якраз від них і
вимагалися дуже компетентно професійно
прокоментувати і порадити що має бути
змінено в цьому
проекті ще дуже важливо що дійсно в
проекті програми 20%
виділено на розсуд самого вчителя і
учнів тобто є сть годин резервного часу
в кожному класі є чотири години на
розвиток мовлення 4тири години на
позакласне читання Це ті години які
вчитель відповідно до програми і
додаткового списку літератури який
дається в кінці програми може сам
обирати а регіони у нас всі різні і
Уявіть собі що програма має бути одна
для всіх абсолютна регіонів України ясно
що всі різні і всім регіонам неможливо
догодити в межах однієї програми тому ми
придумали дуже багато модулів по-перше
варіативність в межах наприклад трьох
творів вчитель різних регіонів може
обрати один за вибором в межах
додаткового списку літератури на
розвиток мовлення або позакласне читання
дати той твір який вони вважають за
потрібне І до речі те що звертаються
вчителі Що наприклад немає твору
Маленький принц Антуана десенткзюпірі
Він є в програмі він був в форматі
проекту під знаком питання тобто ми все
ж та хотіли з'ясувати чи для всіх
регіонів України цей твір залишається
актуальним на сьогодні і ми дуже вдячні
всім абсолютно хто долучився
конструктивно до обговорення проекту
програми що засвідчує толерантність
керівництва Міністерства І дійсно вперше
таке громадське обговорення яке було в
будинку вчителя 5 квітня відбулося в
Україні